BUMILLER: Welcome, everyone.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, everybody.
My name's Elisabeth Bumiller.
I'm the Washington Bureau chief of The New
York Times here.
And welcome to the Council on Foreign Relations
keynote panel discussion to conclude the symposium,
"The New Geopolitics of China, India, and
Pakistan."
This is a very good panel.
We've got three ambassadors up here.
To my immediate right is Ambassador J. Stapleton
Roy, who's a former U.S. ambassador to China.
Long list of-you have his biography.
I imagine many of you already know him.
So here he is, the legend.
(Laughter.)
Next to him is somebody-
ROY: I'm not that old.
(Laughter.)
BUMILLER: I know you also know Ambassador
Wisner-Frank G. Wisner, former U.S. ambassador
to India, many other things.
And then finally, Ambassador Daniel Feldman,
former U.S. special representative for the-for
Afghanistan and Pakistan.
He was deeply involved as a senior official
in setting up that office under Richard Holbrooke,
and worked in that office in some very tense
years, from 2009 to 2015.
So what I'd like to do today, this is on the
record.
I'm going to engage our ambassadors for half
an hour myself.
And then we're going to open up to questions
from the audience for the second half hour.
I'd like to start with Ambassador Feldman.
Just talk-I'd like you to talk a little bit
about your experiences with Pakistan during
a very volatile period in U.S.-Pakistani relations,
specifically after the 2011 raid on Abbottabad
that killed Osama bin Laden, and how you helped
manage the relationship with Pakistan after
that.
And personal recollections would be most welcome.
And then just talk a bit about the nosedive
the relationship took, how you helped to bring
it back, and a bit of where we are now.
I'll ask the others to also recount their
experiences in their specific countries.
And then we're going to have everyone pull
together what this means for the region and
the geopolitics at the end.
So, Dan, take it away.
FELDMAN: Well, thanks.
And very good to be here.
On that question in particular I should call
Marc Grossman back up to the stage, since
he was the special representative at the time,
and on the ground working on many of these
issues.
And I was just supporting him from Washington.
But I think certainly that period in 2011
was one of enormous shocks to the relationship.
I served in the special representative office
and then as special representative for the
final year, but over the six and a half years,
from the very beginning of the administration
in 2009, until last fall.
And I divide my time into kind of three discrete
periods.
And with the asterisks that we're, you know,
potentially on the cusp of a fourth, but I
hope that we're not.
The first one was in that period, 2009 to
2010, when we were really reassessing our
relationship with Pakistan, and sought to
elevate it to these new heights.
We elevated our strategic dialogue to the
ministerial level.
We had several visits by Secretary Clinton
to Pakistan, and visits here by Pakistani
senior officials.
We passed Kerry-Lugar-Berman and the promise
of $7 1/2 billion in civilian assistance over
the course of five years and beyond.
We were reengaging in Afghanistan with the
troop and civilian surge.
And therefore, Pakistan was critical for that
piece as well.
And so it had such high expectations that
it almost certainly wasn't sustainable, and
then it wasn't.
So in 2011, obviously, we saw these series
of shocks.
Abbottabad was actually just one of them.
It started with Ray Davis at the beginning
of 2011.
Followed by Abbottabad-
BUMILLER: Remind the audience.
I mean, most of you know, but just remind
the audience.
FELDMAN: Ray Davis, the U.S. contractor based
at our consulate who was involved in an incident
in killing several Pakistanis, and then it
turned into a significant issue.
I actually in the course of that-it was right
when Marc was starting his tenure as special
representative.
And I think the day he started I was on a
plane with Senator Kerry as we went there
to try to see what was possible, and meeting
with Pakistani civilian and military leadership.
He was ultimately released.
We were starting to just get back on track
and in May we had the Abbottabad raid, which-I
know Marc was on the ground in Pakistan soon
after that, and then Secretary Clinton went
with Admiral Mullen.
By the end of May, after some conversations,
she went again.
And in October, with-what was it-I think it
was General Petraeus and General Dempsey to
have as coordinated a civilian-military intelligence
discussion with senior leadership as possible.
Again, we were kind of just working through
that, and then we had the Salala incident
just before Thanksgiving in 2011, a cross-border
incident where U.S. jets inadvertently killed
24 Pakistani military members.
And it really sent the relationship into the
deep freeze, to the point where they closed
the ground lines of communication supplying
our troops in Afghanistan.
And we really worked very, very assiduously,
under Marc's leadership, over the course of
the first part of 2012 to finally put the
relationship onto firmer footing.
And we achieved that in the summer of 2012,
interestingly, in a State Department diplomatic
channel between our deputy secretary at the
time, Tom Nides, and the finance minister,
Shaikh, in Pakistan, but which was the best
conduit for conversations.
And since 2012, we've really been executing
a much more realistic, much more clear-eyed,
more focused effort at engagement, which really
revolves around building on our core areas
of joint interest on counterterrorism, on
reconciliation, on nuclear nonproliferation,
on economic sustainability and energy.
And so we scaled back the strategic dialogue,
but kept it quite focused.
And this was really the mechanism which kept
our relationship alive during the kind of
annus horribilis.
And over the last three and a half to four
years, it's really borne fruit.
And I think that we have to all be mindful
that despite the continuing challenges-and
there are no doubt that there are very, very
significant challenges still to the relationship
and particularly around counterterrorism issues
with-and proxy groups, whether it's Haqqani,
or LeT, or others.
But there have been real significant developments
in Pakistan over the course of the last three
and a half to four years.
The first democratic transition of a civilian
government, a gradual strengthening of civilian
leadership and that calibration between the
civilian and military leadership.
Certainly increased strides in security, whether
that's in Karachi or the North Waziristan
operation.
The engagement of Pakistan in much more regional
efforts, including the quite significant outreach
to Afghanistan, the effort to try to bring
the Taliban to the table, the quadrilateral
engagement with China and others.
Much better economic sustainability than we'd
seen in decades, in terms of adherence to
the IMF program, grappling with their own
extremist issues, whether as a result of the
Peshawar school massacre, executing Qadri,
the person who murdered Governor Taseer.
But moving forward incrementally.
And I worry that in the last few months, and
especially as some of these flash points have
come to light with the F-16 sale, with coalition
support funds, certainly the limitations of
Afghan patience and tolerance for what Pakistan
can do, and on what time table, as evidence
by President Ghani's comments after the most
recent, you know, horrific attack in Kabul
a few weeks ago, that we're going to forget
the lessons we learned in 2011 and '12, and
the importance of continued engagement.
I want to make sure that we are able to exercise
every bit of leverage that we can.
And there's been a lot of discussion in this
earlier this morning about what the limits
of U.S. power are, and how we utilize it.
But I do want to make sure that we are able
to have at our-that we're able to access every
bit of that, whether that's security assistance,
or civilian assistance, or diplomatic engagement,
or intel cooperation, or incentivizing regional
structures, because at the end of the day
I firmly believe that it's in our national
security interest for us to continue to have
this realistic but very engaged relationship
with Pakistan.
It's important because, for the first time
in six and a half years, we don't have a time-based
condition on our troops in Afghanistan.
So it's having 9,800 troops there currently.
Which we'll have to see, come the next administration,
how long that's continued.
But certainly whether it's just the logistics
of continuing to help supply them or, much
more importantly in my mind, the engagement
of Pakistan in any sort of long-term political
resolution, that would have to come about
for Afghanistan's stability and the reconciliation
process.
We'll want to engage Pakistan, whether it's
nuclear proliferation, whether it's continued
extremism from the second-most populous Muslim
nation in the world.
For all these reasons, we have to continue
on the path that we started down three and
a half years ago.
And it won't be easy.
And it won't be short term.
But it's important and in our interests.
BUMILLER: Thank you.
Frank, do you want to talk a bit about your
experience as the ambassador in Delhi from
'94 to '97.
And that was just the beginnings of India's,
you know, economic growth, just the stirrings
of it.
And you were also helping to manage relationship
between India and Pakistan.
I imagine China was not as big a concern then,
but it was growing.
WISNER: It was.
BUMILLER: OK.
So tell us about that, your life at Roosevelt
House.
WISNER: Elisabeth, thank you.
Perhaps rather than sort of go into excessive
detail about events that took place 22 years
ago, maybe I could take a step back and draw
about three broad conclusions about where
we and the Indians have been over these 22
years, starting where I was in the mid part
of the 1990s.
BUMILLER: OK.
WISNER: And I stood then, and I took off to
go to India, in fact, attended a lunch before
I was even publicly an ambassador with President
Clinton at the time, and P.V.
Narasimha Rao.
The only subject of strategic significance
we discussed was the dispute over almond trade.
Now, why that?
Because in effect, our relationship was really
frozen over the issue of proliferation.
Was India going to test or not test?
And an array of disincentives in the relationship
had grown up.
And we and the Indians really did not have
a serious strategic vision of one another.
If that was the starting point, gosh, what
22 years can do.
The main conclusion I draw, number one, is
that we now deeply believe that a strong India
is good for the United States.
And that we have invested over the course
of two administrations-this one and the Bush
administration, just beginning at the very
end of the Clinton period-in measures to strengthen
India economically, politically, and in defense
terms.
And those have accelerated, particularly after
we got the nuclear problem out of the way,
in 2005 with the decision to settle a civil
nuclear agreement with India.
Now, the interesting counterpart, of course,
has been that India herself has decided, while
maintaining her own stubbornly defended sense
of independence, that the United States is,
in India's mind today, a critical strategic
partner of India's.
BUMILLER: Which did not exist back in the
days-
WISNER: It certainly didn't exist when I started.
And if you want to just take a look at it
and think about it, in just a couple of weeks,
June 7th and 8th, Prime Minister Modi will
be coming here and will be addressing a joint
session of Congress.
Vajpayee did the same.
Inconceivable in previous years in this relationship,
such has been the transformation.
But having said that, being point number one,
point number two is be very careful as you
look forward to think about this relationship.
For India will be not a full-scale great power
anytime in the future.
By 2050, if my memory is correct, India will
control about 7 percent of the world GDP.
China will be controlling 20.
We and the Europeans about 17 percent.
Result is that India will be a lesser figure,
albeit an extremely important one.
And India will be humbled furthermore by a
relatively weak economy that proves very difficult
to change and has major shortfalls in infrastructure,
and health, and education, tax systems.
But the second great weakness of the Indian
establishment is the weakness of Indian state
institutions.
India has a brilliant diplomatic service.
You could put it on the head of a pin.
It has a tiny intelligence service compared
to the requirements of a major regional or
even global power.
India's military is just now reforming itself.
India has a way to go to grow into-to have
the armor of a significant power and player.
The third feature that humbles India is ironically
the other side of the equation that we like
about India.
It's a democracy, but it makes it very difficult
to get decisions made.
You have hotly contested politics in Delhi,
and then you have a diffusion of power throughout
the states.
So India doesn't move quickly to make decisions.
She heads in a more glacial place.
And I think that we have to get used to.
But none of these points should take away
from our mind that India is a hugely important
player for us, especially in the Asia-Pacific
area in maintaining the balance of power.
And so, Elisabeth, let me end with a third
point very quickly, is now to think forward.
What should we be trying to accomplish as
Modi comes now and as a new administration
follows on?
And I think it's really important that we
stay focused on India reality and potential,
recognizing the limitations.
But the way to do it is to stay focused on
what we're doing right now, which is promoting
economic change and reform, promoting the
building of economic ties between our sector,
private sector, and the Indian economy, and
moving robustly, as we have in defense cooperation,
both in supply of defense articles, mil-mil
cooperation, intelligence sharing, these transformative
features that have made the relationship very
important.
The second point that I think is just critical
is not only continuing what we're doing, but
deepening it, deepening it political.
Thinking with the Indians about how we deal
with major questions like China, how we deal
with major regional questions in their near
neighborhood-Iran and the Middle East-and
how we are prepared-what contingencies the
United States is prepared to act on, and how
India would pay in those contingencies to
begin to structure a more sophisticated approach
to India as a regional-cum-global partner
of the United States.
And finally, in that regard, to steal a line
from Alyssa this morning, and that is we should
play for India's introduction to the global
high table.
We were right to put forward-or back the candidacy
of India for the Security Council.
I don't think it's going to happen any time
soon, but it's the right direction.
But APEC is a very smart move of the United
States.
Not that we can rule the roost of 40 countries,
but we certainly can help India get there.
And India can help herself, to answer Evan's
reservations this morning, by looking at what
APEC does, the conventions, APEC's reach.
Many of them match reforms India's already
undertaken, and show that she'd be interested
in playing in those fields as she becomes
a candidate for membership in APEC, and then
in a broader trade and political dimension
that would flow from it.
So a bit of the past and a bit of the future.
BUMILLER: Thanks.
And now, Ambassador Roy, who overlapped a
bit when you were ambassador to China.
The same as when Frank was ambassador to India,
you were there, ambassador from '91 to '95.
I want you to-because we're-I want you to
sum up a bit.
I mean, just before we open up for questions.
I want you to talk about China and your role
there, but I also want you to answer the bigger,
larger question-because this is about the
geopolitics of China, India, and Pakistan-is
I think there was an earlier comment today
that the U.S. no longer has any ability to
shape outcomes in South Asia, Central Asia.
Even though we have spent 15 years in Afghanistan,
billions of dollars, we still have 9,800 troops
in Afghanistan indefinitely at this point,
Americans are in combat still in Afghanistan
as we learned from the Kunduz bombing earlier
last year, but we have not invested economically
the way China has.
So I'd like you to take that on and talk about
China, but also answer that larger question
of whether we can affect outcomes there, and
if we should be investing more economically,
competing with China.
What do you think?
ROY: Let me begin with a little bit of history,
just to illustrate why I have found this program
today so fascinating.
In anticipation of this opportunity today,
in 1945, after seven years in wartime China,
the U.S. Army Air Corps, which operated the
only airline at the time between China and
India, flew my family and me to Calcutta,
where I spent a week investigating the situation
on the ground there.
We then took a train across India to Bombay,
where we spent a month.
The war in the Pacific was still continuing,
but we were able to get a ship back to New
York.
Jump from there to 1962, when I was serving
in our embassy in China, which was located
in Taipei, Taiwan, of course.
And I'd just gotten then when the war between
China and India broke out.
And it's no secret that the sympathies of
the Americas were with the democratic Indians
in their struggle against the godless communists.
And '62 was not the high point of cross-strait
relations between Taiwan and China at the
time.
And I discovered, to my interest, that the
sympathies of the government in Taiwan were
entirely with Beijing.
They thought that Beijing was acting in defense
of China's interests.
So free China was on communist China's side
in the-in the '62 war.
The United States was not on that side.
It gave me a useful insight into the fact
that nationalism, in many ways, is more important
than ideology in determining in how you locate
your thing.
Since then, while I was ambassador in Beijing
in 1992, I spent 10 days in Xinjiang and visited
Ili and Kashgar, which are the opening points
to Kyrgyzstan and to Tajikistan.
And of course, Central Asia had just become
independent.
They'd just opened the rail link through Ili
into Kyrgyzstan.
But it was after centuries of essentially
a closed situation because the Russian Empire
in Central Asia was established under Catherine
the Great, largely.
And at roughly the same time the Qing dynasty,
in China, in its early days, established Chinese
control over Xinjiang again.
It had control there 1,500 years earlier.
But during the Ming dynasty they were weak
in that area.
And it was in that period when they established
Xinjiang as part of China again.
I mention this because the whole purpose of
this session is to talk about the changing
geopolitics of this region.
And I throw in Central Asia.
And I was struck by the discussion this morning.
Russia was barely mentioned.
And I think it's an egregious error that we
are making to leave.
On East Asia I can spend, you know, a week-long
conference and Russia is barely touched on.
And here we are, talking about South Asia,
and failing to mention that Russia has very
strong interests in the areas abutting on
Afghanistan, Pakistan, and India to the north.
India, Pakistan are very conscious of this.
We, Americas, somehow seem to drop this out.
Now, this is relevant because we have three
things that have really happened that are
affecting this dynamic in a big way.
Number one is the rise of China and India.
Thirty years ago they were big countries,
but they were not, shall we say, great powers.
Now they have emerged these great powers,
and largely through economic development,
rather than their military strength.
The second is the opening up of Central Asia
with the collapse of the Soviet Empire in
Central Asia, which has created a no-man's
land for strategic competition among countries
that are interested in the region.
And that includes Russia, it includes China,
it includes India.
And Pakistan, of course, is deeply concerned
about what happens in that part of the world.
So enormous changes are taking effect.
This is a transformational period, because
for the first time in recent history one great
power-China-has the economic resources to
see the potential for extending its influence
into Central Asia and South Asia and the Middle
East through the development of communications,
transportation, trade.
China is India's number-one trading partner.
China is the number-one trading partner of
the Central Asian countries.
China has this historic relationship with
Pakistan.
And our role in the region is a military role.
Back in the old days, we had an economic arm
to play.
Now, essentially, we have a military hand
to play, and we either play it well or we
play it badly.
But what's driving the transformational changes
in this region is economics.
There is clearly a very important strategic
element to China's One Belt, One Road initiative,
because China is-has an ambition to become
a global naval power.
It's already a global maritime power through
its civil maritime fleet.
But it's the economic element of China's move
into the region that is the transformational
element.
We've talked about Silk Road initiatives and
had no economic resources to back it up.
China has major economic resources to back
it up.
So, from the U.S. standpoint, our problem
is, essentially because of budgetary problems
in the United States, we're only funding our
military to be able to play a robust international
role.
And if it turns out that the military component
of our national strength is inadequate to
produce the political outcomes that we would
like to see, and we're competing with countries
such as China who have major economic resources
to put behind it-even India's investments
in this area, I think, dwarf what we are prepared
to do at this present time.
BUMILLER: Well, so here's my question, before
I open it up.
What should-what should the United States
do in this case?
What is the role of the United States?
Should the United States resist this in some
way, and try to spend billions of dollars
in the region?
Or should the United States deal with what
seems to be reality and work in some way with-try
to work with China in the region and accept
that it's a new power in the region?
ROY: I'll offer a quick view on this, because
I think my colleagues here will have-
BUMILLER: Right.
ROY: First of all, essentially, we have two
choices.
We're going to continue a more limited military
role in the area, so it's not that we're not
a player.
But in terms of the economic drive, the infrastructure
development that is a very important transformational
element, we have a choice of either remaining
on the outside, playing a carping role, and
perhaps objecting to or trying to obstruct
the efforts by the other major players to
carve out their own role in the process; or
we can get involved in it as a junior partner.
We can't play the role of a major partner
because we don't have the economic resources
to deal with it.
But if we don't stay involved, we will not
be able to track what is going on effectively.
The problem is, if we try to resist it, we're
going to show our weakening position in the
world.
I think that's the lesson we ought to learn
from AIIB.
What happened is we saw that our closest European
allies were unprepared to take guidance from
the United States on whether or not they should
associate themselves with the bank.
We are going to show ourselves as a declining
power if we try to oppose forces that are
stronger than our resistance can possibly
be.
So my judgment is we need to pay attention
to this world because the geopolitical transformations
taking place in the heart of the Eurasian
continent have global implications-involve
China, Russia, India, Pakistan, Japan, they're
all part of this game.
And we need to be deeply involved in this,
and at the moment we only have the military
component to our strategy.
And I think that's a real limitation on what
we can do.
BUMILLER: So are the other panelists in violent
agreement or disagreement?
(Laughs.)
WISNER: I can't resist wrestling with Strobe
because-excuse me, Stape-(laughter)-because
I really genuinely see the matters through
a different perspective.
To me, the role of the United States, as I
see it, in South Asia but more broadly throughout
East Asia, as a critical component in the
maintenance of a balance of power-that our
relationship with Japan and with Korea is
critical in their eyes to maintain their sense
of defense with regard to China.
And so it is with Vietnam, the Philippines.
And the extension: the same is true with India.
India sees the United States and its relationship
with us as part of its ability to secure itself
in the long term and manage its own relations
with a rising Chinese power.
In addition, American political presence plays
a vital role inside of Southeast Asia and
South Asia, Pakistan and Afghanistan.
The Afghans look to the United States to be
a balancer in their relationship with Pakistan.
The Paks have long bid for our hand in trying
to equalize matters with India.
So this political structure that we have been-we
have as a nation is critical to our influence
in the world and to the way the Asian nations,
including India, are prepared to look at us.
So I think we have a lot more going for us
than, Stape, you would-the weight of your
remarks would indicate.
Moreover, and coming back to a question I
put to the panel this morning, I think we
have economic capability.
No, we will not compete with China as providing
an alternate supply chain or source of capital
in the crudest sense of development banks.
But TPP is our-is our brainchild, our creation.
The ability to provide Asia alternatives in
Asia's trading world, economic growth, manufacturing
capabilities, is very much tied to our interests.
And I think the offer of TPP, and why nations
as diverse as Japan and Latin Americans are
all embracing it, precisely is to have that
economic alternative.
And China is today herself struggling how
she will relate to it.
It's a very powerful political and economic
tool.
So, for these two reasons, plus the military-and
I recognize its vital importance, but I literally,
Stape, give it third rank in my hierarchy
of important tools available to the United
States.
Very important that we maintain our forward
deployments, our military-to-military ties,
our defense trade ties.
All of these undergird our security system.
But keep an eye on the politics and the economics.
They're very powerful.
BUMILLER: Last word, quick word.
FELDMAN: Yeah, I would-I would just say, I
don't-I certainly don't see the U.S. and China
relationship as a-as a competitive one at
this point in South Asia, or that it shouldn't
be, and one that is actually very complementary.
I think that we have very aligned interests
at this point in the stability in the region.
And it's incumbent upon us to continue to
help drive the strategic relationship and
some of the initiatives, and to the degree
we are engaged, we continue to be engaged
militarily but also economically.
I guess I don't see-I've never seen the One
Belt, One Road as something where we would
be a JV partner in because I think it fulfills
many of the ambitions that we initially laid
out when we talked about the New Silk Road,
first when Secretary Clinton raised it in
summer 2011 in Chennai, and then the New Silk
Road summit that we had-or ministerial at
UNGA that year.
Yes, we're not-there was an earlier question
about Kerry-Lugar-Berman, and there were certainly
significant constraints on what we were able
to achieve there, but it's quite remarkable
that China's commitment-whether it's 46 billion
(dollars), or at the end of the day 23 billion
(dollars), or even less than that-is completely
aligned with what we prioritized for our assistance:
energy, infrastructure, and in fact, doing
things that we are incapable of doing abroad,
whether due to constraints on funding coal
projects or nuclear projects or oil and gas.
So we all have this common interest in a more
stable and economically sustainable Pakistan,
a Pakistan that's not isolated, a South Asia
that's not, I think, riven between U.S.-aligned
and China-aligned interests.
And these are opportunities to continue to
foster and facilitate that.
I hope that we can continue to develop these
tools in our own tool chest, whether on civilian
assistance or doing more on trade rather than
getting stuck on-in the same discussions of
FTAs or BITs or anything else, and figure
out other ways to incentivize behavior and
contribute.
But this is an area that Pakistan itself has
said that they want to pivot to, to much more
trade rather than aid.
And I guess just lastly before we open it
up for questions, I think that the regional
engagement here, this is a significant moment
of opportunity still, given the changes over
the last few years-historic democratic transitions
of power in Afghanistan as well as Pakistan,
the Modi election in India, the continued
engagement of China in the region.
We'll see what happens with Iran.
This should be a moment when we can capitalize
on formulating and strengthening regional
alliances.
The economic piece, I think, is the most natural
lowest-hanging fruit, and we've seen that
over the last few years in CASA-1000 and TAPI.
But there's much, much more to do, both in
terms of soft and hard linkages.
And I think we play a critical role in helping
to continue that trend.
BUMILLER: Great, thank you.
OK, questions?
Right here in the front row, front table.
Q: Hi, thanks.
My name is Alan Kronstadt.
I'm with the Congressional Research Service.
And I wanted to maybe press on Pakistan a
little with Ambassador Feldman.
Giving a different narrative to the story
of the last few years, you had offered maybe
a more realistic engagement since 2012 had
borne fruit.
And one of those fruits was kind of the democratic
transition, the-you know, the election and
a-and a peaceful transition of power.
Now, there is an argument that that was less
a function of U.S. engagement and maybe advice,
and more a function of Pak mil's own assessment
of its role in the society and what role it
wanted to play in domestic governments-governance.
Likewise, the military operations in the FATA
region, perhaps less a function of U.S. interest
and engagement and more a function of the
Pak mil's response to the Karachi airport
attack or the 2014 Peshawar school attack,
and that when it comes to areas that the U.S.
has really been keenly interested-action against
the Haqqani Network, Lashkar-e-Taiba, Jaish-e-Mohammed;
also, strengthening rather than just abiding
the existence of a democratic government-Pakistan
has fallen short.
Maybe also nuclear proliferation and planning
issues.
And so, setting aside any question of the
next U.S. administration's policy toward Pakistan,
there have been some signs on Capitol Hill
of a-of a growing skepticism, maybe emerging
wariness.
We've seen a reduction of overall aid amounts,
coalition support funds, also non-waivable
conditions on coalition support funds for
the first time in the post-9/11 era, and most
recently, you know, some senior members of
Congress insisting that Pakistan not be subsidized
in a purchase of F-16s.
And further than that, there's analysts who
are-who are counseling for a more rigorous,
maybe sterner approach to Pakistan policy,
maybe even could be called punitive in some
ways, as an alternative, who would reflect
upon the last four years as not in general
gaining the outcomes or realizing the outcomes
that the U.S. government has sought.
So I'm just curious if you could respond to
that, please.
FELDMAN: Sure.
I mean, first of all, I mean, just to clarify,
I by no means mean to overstate what the U.S.
engagement led to.
It was not the precipitating factor for a
democratic transition.
It was probably not the one for a North Waziristan
operation.
Obviously, these issues are being driven by
domestic politics, by domestic security issues,
by domestic interests, as they would be in
virtually any country around the world.
I think China's engagement on counterterrorism
issues is driven far more by their concerns
on ETIM than by other nations seeking to engage
them in some of these things.
But I do think that we can look for areas
of alignment where the natural Pakistani trajectory
aligns with our own interests.
And we have that on counterterrorism.
We have that on strengthening civilian institutions.
And by all means, I mean, I think said it
every time I testified to Congress, every
time I spoke publicly and privately: there
is far more that we expect of the Pakistanis
in addressing proxy groups, in dealing with
safe havens.
This was said frequently and specifically
and strongly and repeatedly by all my predecessors,
by Secretary Clinton, by Secretary Kerry,
and we have to continue to push for that.
But I don't think that isolating or being
more punitive at this point is the way to
change a strategic calculus.
And, in fact, I'm not sure that we can change
a strategic calculus.
So I understand the reasons, and I don't even
necessarily disagree with more conditionality,
more transparency, more reporting.
But I don't think-but I think it has to be
calibrated, and we have to make sure that
we're looking at it over the long term in
terms of what's going to best serve our interests
for the coming years.
BUMILLER: Would you like-
WISNER: Elisabeth, yeah, would you let me
add a short word?
BUMILLER: Of course, of course.
WISNER: Just over a decade ago, if my memory
serves me well-actually, slightly more than
a decade ago-this institution, the Council
on Foreign Relations, with the notable management
of Alyssa Ayres, participation of Marshall
Bouton in the back of the room, came out with
a terrific study of United States relations
with South Asia.
And as we looked at the question of Pakistan
from the very beginning of our relationship
with Pakistan in the 1950s right through the
mid-2004/5 period, the single most dangerous
element in that relationship was the roller
coaster that we put the relationship on: our
willingness to engage, back off, re-engage,
impose conditions, change, back and forth,
up and down.
And loss of influence was just one of the
consequences.
And if there was one conclusion of something
that was written a decade-plus ago is, get
of the roller coaster.
Recognize that you deal with the conditions
of other nations and what you want them to
do over the long run by patient application
of dialogue, and you don't get it by imposing
lots of short-term conditions and cutoff threats.
FELDMAN: The roller-coaster analogy is very
apt.
And I sometimes say, not so much that I've
experienced the arc of the relationship, but
the sine and cosine of the relationship over
the-over the last few years.
And all I'm saying is that we have to just
try to stabilize it more.
It has to be-it's in our own interest to continue
a much more linear and pragmatic approach
rather than let ourselves be subject to these
whims, whether it's an F-16 sale with sovereign
funds or not, or whether-whatever the most
recent issue may be.
BUMILLER: Let's see, go to the back of the
room to another member.
Here in the red tie, yes.
Q: Hi.
My name is Austat (ph).
I'm on the Pakistan desk-(comes on mic)-hello.
I'm on the Pakistan-I'm in SRAP at the moment,
working in the-in the political component
of the Pakistan desk.
And I have a very simple question: What will
change Pakistan's calculus?
FELDMAN: Shouldn't I be looking to you for
that answer?
(Laughter, laughs.)
Q: I'm searching for wisdom.
(Laughter.)
FELDMAN: (Laughs.)
I think we have to-I mean, there's plenty
of Pakistan experts here, including the woman
to your right and many others.
I think that-I think, again, in the interest
of being realistic and clear-eyed, we have
to recognize what we can and cannot do.
And, you know, there was a lot of talk earlier
in the administration about what will change
the strategic calculus.
And I think that, at the end of the day, it's
very, very little.
It's working with them to-if there are issues,
as perhaps the Peshawar incident was, if there
are others that can demonstrate that they
have a vested interest in dealing with these
issues in their own society for the stability
of their own country, to do what is right
by the Pakistani entrepreneurs, to try to
grow a civil society, that they have to take
certain steps-which we can help them on, but
we can't do for them-that that is ultimately
the realization that we all have to help encourage.
BUMILLER: Yes, here on the left in the salmon-colored
sweater.
Q: Thanks very much.
I'm Garrett Mitchell.
I write The Mitchell Report.
And on the day when Donald Trump has become
I think officially the presumptive nominee
of the Republican Party, I want to pose a
question that I-if it sounds facetious, it
is not intended to be.
But I was thinking about having a conversation
like this in a room that isn't filled with
people who associate with the Council on Foreign
Relations, but filled with people who are
leaning in the Trump direction, however one
wants to characterize them-isolationist, nativist,
or something less pejorative.
I was wondering how we might frame some of
the thoughts that you've been expressing,
but without vocabulary that isn't going to
fly with apparently a lot of voters.
They don't know about strategic alliances
or strategic partnerships.
They're not-they don't know what a TTIP is,
they know what a Q-tip is.
How do we-how do we-I'm not suggesting that
we-that we all learn how to talk like Donald
Trump, but how do we-how do we make these
points to an audience of people who need to
hear something different, but who also need
to understand the validity of what you're
talking about?
BUMILLER: That's a very good question.
Who wants to take a bite at that?
WISNER: Stape?
(Laughter.)
I'm happy to.
ROY: As I understand Donald Trump's position,
it's that our allies are having a free ride,
and that they should either pay the freight
or we'll get off the bus.
I think if he were to be elected president,
he would discover that you can't deal with
the world outside of our borders on that basis.
In other words, diplomacy is the business
of influencing people, and offering people
take-it-or-leave-it propositions generally
is not a good generic way of influencing them.
But I'm going to draw on some earlier comments
here, because I have generally-I generally
agree with what Frank Wisner and Dan said,
but I'd package it differently.
I think the problem that whoever becomes the
U.S. president is going to discover is that
having the largest economy in the world is
irrelevant in public policy terms.
In public policy terms, what is the criterion
of the strength of your economy is the ability
of the political system to extract the economic
resources necessary to play a great power
role.
We went into World War II totally unprepared,
not because our economy was so weak it couldn't
be prepared, but because our political system
would not permit us to become prepared.
At the moment, our political system is funding
the military component of our international
presence and is grossly underfunding all of
the other aspects of our comprehensive power
in a world where we are cooperating with and
competing with rising powers such as China
and India.
I also think that we have to make some important
distinctions in looking at the world.
In East Asia, our balancing role is vital,
and India is a bit player in this respect.
In South Asia, I would offer you it's not
the United States who can play a balancing
role, because India wants to play the balancing
role.
And what we have discovered in our relationship
with India is it's so determined to be the
balancer that it won't get into the U.S. pocket.
That's why it doesn't buy U.S. aircraft.
It buys them from other people, even though
we thought that our new relationship was going
to guarantee us some military sales.
It doesn't work out that way.
Pakistan does not consider us a reliable ally
because of this roller coaster that we have
had repeatedly there.
China is the factor that's important to Pakistan
because it is reliable, it's there, it gives
it military support-up to limits.
Let's not forget that when we've had Pakistan-India
rows, China doesn't throw its national interest
in vainly to try to alter that balance.
But the fact of the matter is that China is
seen by Pakistan as a reliable ally and the
United States is seen as one-as a fair-weather
friend.
Simply the history of the last 10 years-why
did we develop the Northern Transportation
Network?
It was because Pakistan wouldn't permit us
to move goods through Pakistan to Afghanistan.
BUMILLER: But what do you say a to a roomful
of Trump supporters right now to explain what
you just said?
What is the simple explanation for why the
United States has to engage in the world?
What do you tell-I'm not going to say it,
actually-but what do you-(laughter)-
WISNER: Got it.
ROY: OK.
FELDMAN: What's the bumper sticker?
WISNER: Well, let me-
ROY: Very briefly-
BUMILLER: OK, anybody.
And yeah-
WISNER: I'll follow.
ROY: Since the beginning of our Republic,
the economic factor has been the basis of
our national strength.
At the moment, China has a stronger trade
relationship with all of our friends and allies
in East Asia.
China has more trade-is the largest trading
partner of India, more so than we are.
In other words, in dealing with the world,
the United States is going to be a loser if
we are not able to play a role other than
the military factor, which is our trump card
at the moment, if you will, is that military
factor.
BUMILLER: But we're losing jobs here because
of that.
What do you say to that?
WISNER: Well, it's-I think-
ROY: I say we lose jobs when job move from
Massachusetts to North Carolina.
The fact that we're moving it over-the reason
why East Asia has been a success story is
because the jobs move where they are economically
most properly placed.
It's not the question of losing jobs.
It's that our jobs-the jobs that we have lost
are not jobs that belong in the United States,
but we haven't substituted the jobs that belong
in the United States where we have the competitive
advantage.
And that's the transformation that we have
to make in our own economy and we need to
have the government policies that will facilitate
that.
BUMILLER: Did you have a-
WISNER: I like that, yeah.
I would particularly state the last thing
you said.
And it goes, I believe to the question you
put to us.
I think whoever wins this election-Donald
Trump or Hillary Clinton, or whoever wins
it-(laughter)-we're going to be faced with
the-
BUMILLER: Paul Ryan.
WISNER: We've had enough surprises this far.
(Laughter.)
Whoever wins it, we're faced with an American
public that is deeply skeptical of use of
expressions like national interest and trade
agreements.
And we have a job of rebuilding a consensus
behind policy again.
We have a country that has not recovered fully
from our recession and a country that has
overextended-believes its overextended itself
in wars in Iraq and Afghanistan.
So how do address the question of-I think
you're absolutely right.
Set aside words like national interest and
go to the heart of the matter.
What's going to produce American power, so
that we have influence in the world where
we and our wishes in the world will be listened
to by other nations?
And that's a mixture of the strength of our
military, the skill of our diplomacy, the
quality of our intelligence.
And it's there through our alliance system,
and being able to multiply our message through
the mouths of close associates and allies
around the world, and be feared when necessary,
but have the power to deliver, point one.
Point two is economics.
It's all good and well to say trade makes
jobs.
But unless we can prove to Americans that
when we displace that job in Pottstown, Pennsylvania
and move it to China or to Malaysia, and replace
it with a higher-paying job and help the worker
who is losing in Pennsylvania find his way
forward, we've really-we've really, really
not addressed a major societal problem.
And I think when I look at the prospect of
selling TPP, for example, leave the word out
of it, trade agreements of any sort, I think
the two great selling points we're going to
have to focus on is, number one, trade adjustment.
How do you create inside the structure of
your agreements the ability to train your
people and upgrade their skills, and make
that real, and help people move from point
A in the economy to point B. Second, I think
it's going to be very important to deal with
the environmental question.
And that is, how we use trade agreements to
improve the life we live, the quality of the
air we breathe, the environment and the climate
that we are a part of.
If I were to sit down and re-explain TPP today,
and look at a Trump voter in the face, I would
be able to say: I'll deliver better on those
two questions than anyone who talks simply
about tearing up an agreement.
BUMILLER: Dan-
FELDMAN: Yeah, I'll just say very, very quickly.
I think it's a great question and I concur
with everything that's been said.
And I think that it's something that the campaign-the
Clinton campaign will be struggling with for
the next six months.
Putting aside the question that I'm not actually
sure what any of Donald Trump's policies would
be on this, but I would say that boiling it
down to a bare minimum that the U.S. cannot
be great if we do it in isolation.
That at the end of the day, it's not just
about national security interests, but better
defining and communicating what that means
to these voters.
And I would say we cannot be as safe as possible
and we cannot be as prosperous as possible
without our engagement with the rest of the
global community.
And certainly-and then demonstrate examples
by which that's true.
I think in my case, in Afghanistan, it could
not be more evident that we would not have
been able to accomplish what we've accomplished
thus far, and recognizing that it's still
extremely fragile, but without NATO, without
the international community.
And as we set up our-the contact group that
Marc talked about with the other special representatives
from 50 other countries engaged, we made sure
that it was-there was about a third from Muslim-majority
countries, so it wasn't just a clash of civilizations,
that the regional component continues to be
important.
And that can't be driven by us.
We can help to facilitate and nurture it,
but we have to continue to encourage that.
And we don't have a voice at that table, which
is in our own interest if we're not engaged.
But I do think it has to be boiled down to
that minimal-to that degree of a talking point.
BUMILLER: Well, thank you to all three of
you.
Thank you to the members.
And that concludes the panel.
(Applause.)
(END)